before we have a go at this before we
haven't got this i want to show you how
to do this wrong you know I need to show
you a really common error with this
because it's so common and they want to
show you how how what we've already
developed on how to approach the battery
will save it from this counter okay so I
want you to listen through and I heard
this I speak this out you spot the flaws
in my logic but if they're not immediate
you think very hard about what's going
on okay so here's what I'm going to
think about this um I'm going to say
look I know what cos inverse normally
looks like i have a picture in my head I
just for the sake of it you've already
got to picture there but I just dropped
it off this I think should suffice okay
this caused it most so I think about all
right what's going to happen to this to
make it this okay he's my fault process
mm-hmm I see you too I see you too so I
know what that means that's going to
change the horizontal so its title does
that make sense make it tight okay so i
know that looks like instead of being
negative 1 to 1 negative 1 to 1 that's
getting negative a half to a half yours
darling okay that normally is what
happens everything gets sort of
compressed so far so good I know what
that means that means i have to shift
horizontally right negative means i go
in the positive direction okay so this
is not going to go from negative half to
a half anymore it's going to go from
well if i add one to everything because
going to the right one unit right that's
going to become a half hour it's going
to become one and a half yeah okay
that's that's one unit everything's
going forward a half and one and a half
so this is the picture I have in my head
now and then i work at this part i
usually go from naught to pi naught 2 pi
so i should only go half that far so I
think this is going to be PI on too
looks reasonable right except for the
fact that it's wrong now the question is
why is it wrong where was the floor in
my logic because i did like i did is the
right you know thickness and if you put
a negative one that usually does shift
you one unit to the right so what's
going on what happens is that well you
said that you shifted one here it's not
actually one unit haha ok oh let me take
that thought it's not actually one unit
it's half because there's a tube because
like you put it inside the light room
inside the minus 12 x minus one so how
would you suggest i rewrite this you'll
factor yep ok so I'm going to factorize
out there's a 2 there which is a weird
thing to factorize out because a lot of
common factor is it right but I look at
this I'm like that's as simple as it
gets I don't touch this but in fact that
should please why this is really what's
happening this is really what's
happening ok this is a bit confusing
because kind of like what why should i
do it that way is not obvious at all
like i said if someone showed you this
abyss and said which one is simpler i'm
pretty sure we also this way it looks
better ok however i remember how i said
before to make clear what is going on
you should always move rearrange numbers
coefficients shooting constant that kind
of thing move them over to whatever
they're acting on to make it clear
what's going on that's why the move
things over the why this is not really a
one acting on this X or negative one
should say the negative one is actually
acting on 2x it shouldn't do that right
that's why factory out makes is clear
now let me help you see that ok let's do
one let's do this domain and range thing
let's do it that's a project
algebraically and even I'm going to skip
this step ok I'm going to go back to one
before and all I'm going to do is move
that half over when it's on the left
hand side let's go Bo to all right so it
looks like this
okay let's think about domain and then
we'll think about range what's the
regular domain of cos inverse know what
21 okay so negative 1 to 1 there it is
okay I'm just going to do my normal
normal algebra so I'm not going to think
about the visuals I'm going to work with
this until I get some inside out of it
what should I do to all of these
components to start simplifying I think
adding one is the most logical thing to
do first right did you notice that
adding what is the logical thing to do
first like when you think about why
should I walk around with so I'm going
to do that I'm going to add one to
everything which gives me this and you
immediately notice what's going here
right when you divide through which is
the next listen the only thing you can
do left you're getting this which tells
you this is wrong right even before you
think about our which way am I supposed
to go just the algebra on the domain
tells you something has gone wrong here
in my logic okay maybe what I did was I
Shrunk things down first and then I
moved them in fact I should have moved
and then shrunk second right which is
exactly what happened here I moved and
then I shrunk okay Sarah go if you do it
the other way it works so long as you
remember what we were saying before
about the factorization but this is in
fact this okay I'm gonna point out some
more important examples of that later on
but this is still perfectly sufficient
and it's much less error-prone people
get this wrong all the time even when
they know they have to do it let's fix
up the range which is not where the
tricks aren't really what am I going to
do to the rain it's normally what's it
normally not to play so not to PI but I
don't have why I've got to I so that's
why i delay through
and that part was fine okay so what
should my graph shall he look like not
like either of those right it's going to
look like me this I've entirely in the
first quadrant which I read off the
domain and range I'm gonna go from where
am I going to go from here ok I can fix
up all my numbers that's going to be one
harm and here is my equation ok that
makes sense so watch out for these kinds
of things this is not the only way it
happens by the way for instance an
identical kind of thing can happen if I
said don't don't draw this but just
think it through to me if I stare a half
cos inverse of hmm how about this ok now
we're not going to draw it just think it
through with me ok hmm we know it's
going to happen to the range the range
is the easy part if I do the algebra
take this approach that Makino is
suggesting before right because actually
it is a little more helpful here if I go
ahead and do this i could rewrite it
like this now on the face of it that
looks like a shift in which direction on
the face of it it looks like a shift to
the left doesn't it like if I asked you
to draw this and then ask you to draw
this I know you'd all draw one parabola
on the origin and then the other one
with the turret negative one we're
really good at this but this is a lot of
shift to the left it's not a shifting
left at all right it's a shift to the
right because what's really happening
there's a negative that should be taken
it up right that negative there means
what you're left with after you
factorize is this and now it's clear
actually a shift to the right and then
there's a horizontal flip right there's
that shift and then there's that flip ok
so this kind of thing is very helpful
because I will point out the domain of
this and the domain of how I flipped and
round will be
same right so the inequalities won't
tell you which direction it's facing
where I to put a horizontal flip on this
it's going to look like sine inverse is
it it's going to become an increasing
function will do some like this but the
domain arranged themselves don't tell
you that they just tell you where you
could go not how you get from one side
to the other does that make sense so
learning this way a factorizing is
useful but it can get a bit confusing if
you don't have this firmly in your mind
first okay so that's my advice